Cyrus the Great: The King of Kings
In the 6th century BC, Cyrus II of Persia
embarked on a mission of conquest.
Kingdom after kingdom fell before him as he
formed the Achaemenid Empire, the largest
empire that the world had ever seen up until
that point.
It kept growing under successors like Cambyses
and Darius until it, too, fell under the might
of Alexander the Great during the late 4th
century BC.
Cyrus left behind him a rich legacy, but one
which is still filled with uncertainties,
mythologies, and misapprehensions.
He has a reputation not only as a conqueror,
but also as an innovative administrator and
a pioneer of human rights.
How much of that is deserved we will try to
find out now as we look at the life of Cyrus,
the Great King.
Legendary Beginnings
Cyrus II was born ca. 600 BC in Anshan, an
ancient city ruled by his father, King Cambyses
I.
His mother was Mandane, a daughter of Astyages,
king of the Median Empire.
Greek historian Herodotus gives us a very
detailed and dramatic account of Cyrus’s
childhood.
However, it leans heavily on the mythological
side but, then again, so do most ancient sources
that deal with Cyrus.
According to Herodotus, the marriage between
Cambyses and Mandane occurred after Astyages
had a prophetic dream where water flowed from
his daughter’s womb and flooded his kingdom.
He consulted with his magi who concluded that
his dream was a foreboding vision that meant
the downfall of his empire.
Astyages wanted to place his daughter somewhere
safe and out of the way.
That’s why he married her to Cambyses, a
Persian who ruled over a small and weak city
which would surely pose no threat to his kingdom.
Soon afterwards, the Median king had another
dream.
This time, vines sprouted out of his daughter’s
womb, covering the kingdom.
Astyages and his magi took this to mean that
Mandane’s offspring was the one who would
prove to be his downfall.
The conclusion was simple - the child had
to die.
When Cyrus was born, Astyages gave him to
one of his most trusted servants, a Mede named
Harpagus.
The king commanded him to take the child home,
kill him and bury him.
Harpagus agreed, but couldn’t go through
with it.
Instead, he gave the baby to a cowherd named
Mitradates and ordered him to do the evil
deed by leaving the child in the “most desolate
part of the mountains.”
Mitradates agreed, but also couldn’t bring
himself to do it.
As it happened, his own wife had been pregnant
and had just given birth to a stillborn child.
They decided to pull the old switcheroo and
left their son in the mountains and raised
Cyrus as their own.
The boy was not called Cyrus during this time
and, while Herodotus does not mention his
name, Strabo gives it as Agradates.
Cyrus lived as the son of a cowherd for ten
years until he was found out.
One day, he was playing with the other children
in his village.
He was proclaimed “king” and gave out
orders which one of the other boys refused
to obey.
To address this insult, the “king” had
the other boy beaten.
His father, a noble Mede named Artembares,
complained to the real king.
Because Artembares was an important courtier,
Astyages himself went to talk with the son
of a cowherd and he soon realized his true
identity.
Subsequently, he got the real story out of
Mitradates and, later, Harpagus.
Cyrus got off easy.
Upon renewed consultation with his magis,
Astyages concluded that, since Cyrus was made
“king” by the boys of his village, his
prophetic dream had been fulfilled and, therefore,
the child was no longer a threat.
He was still of Persian blood, though, so
he was sent to live with his birth parents
in Anshan.
The one who truly felt the wrath of Astyages
was Harpagus, the minion who disobeyed the
king’s order.
Outwardly, Astyages showed no ill will towards
Harpagus and even invited him to a feast in
honor of his newly-discovered grandson.
There, he tricked his servant into eating
his own son who had been killed, dismembered,
boiled and roasted before the banquet.
Astyages revealed his malevolent act by presenting
Harpagus with his son’s head, hands, and
feet after he had finished eating.
Publicly, Harpagus reacted calmly, simply
saying that whatever his king did pleased
him.
He collected his son’s remains, buried them
at home and began plotting his revenge.
Conquering Media
In 559 BC, Cyrus ascended to the throne of
Anshan.
Like his predecessor, he had to acknowledge
the authority of the Median Empire and pay
tribute.
Unbeknownst to King Astyages, though, Harpagus
began courting the new king and encouraged
him to get the Persians to rebel against Astyages,
promising that he will get the Medes to do
the same.
Cyrus was onboard with the plan, but needed
to find a way to unite the Persians.
Back then, Persia consisted of multiple tribes
and he required all their strength to stand
against the Kingdom of Media.
Cyrus’s own tribe was the Pasargadae, but
Herodotus also identified the Maraphii, the
Maspii, the Derusiaei, the Panthialaei, the
Germanii, the Dahae, the Mardi, the Dropici,
and the Sagartii.
Cyrus summoned their representatives to him
and told each to bring a sickle.
On the first day, he put them to work and
had them clear and prepare a stretch of land
up to twenty furlongs long in each direction.
On the second day, he had them wash and take
part in a sumptuous feast in a meadow where
wine and food were plentiful.
Afterwards, he simply asked them which day
they preferred and, obviously, everyone answered
the second day.
That is when Cyrus promised those who stood
by him only days like that free of toil and
slavery, while those who opposed him would
have “labors unnumbered.”
Most Persians resented having to submit to
the Medes in the first place, so Cyrus’s
proposition was not exactly a hard sell.
Even so, we do not know if all the tribes
joined in on the revolt, but there were enough
for Cyrus to go to war against the Median
Empire.
In a moment of pure foolishness, Astyages
assigned Harpagus as commander of his army.
We don’t know if he forgot what he did to
his son or if he genuinely believed that his
general had forgiven him for it.
Either way, Harpagus definitely remembered
and had waited patiently to enact his vengeance.
He kept his end of the bargain with Cyrus
and convinced many Medes to betray Astyages.
Therefore, as the Median army marched, many
soldiers deserted while others openly joined
the Persians.
Those who remained loyal to the old king were
defeated in battle.
Not left with much choice, Astyages assembled
another army from the men left in Ecbatana,
the kingdom capital, and led it himself against
Cyrus.
This new force mostly consisted of youths
and old men and they, too, rebelled against
the king and surrendered Astyages over to
Cyrus.
This happened in 550 BC, according to the
Nabonidus Chronicle, and Cyrus the Great entered
triumphantly into Ecbatana.
The Persian king spared Astyages and kept
him around his court until his death.
Cyrus also married one of the Median king’s
daughters, Amytis, which helped strengthen
his legitimacy as a ruler and pacify some
of the Median vassals.
It was the first step in assembling the Achaemenid
Empire.
The Lineage of Cyrus
You might be wondering why a Persian empire
founded by Cyrus was called the Achaemenid
Empire.
It is worth taking a little time to explore
his lineage and try to present it as best
we understand it.
The dynasty is named after Achaemenes, the
apical ancestor from which all the rulers
of the First Persian Empire descended.
Whether or not he actually existed, though,
is still a matter of some debate.
The main source we have for his existence
is the Behistun Inscription, a giant rock
relief carved into Mount Behistun in the Zagros
Mountains.
Commissioned by King Darius the Great, the
inscription tells of his own rise to power.
Scholars are fascinated by the Behistun Inscription
because it was vital in helping them understand
cuneiform script as the inscription was written
in three different languages: Old Persian,
Elamite, and Babylonian.
In that regard, this monument is similar to
the Rosetta Stone which helped us decipher
hieroglyphs.
To us, it is relevant because, in the first
section, Darius traces his lineage all the
way back to Achaemenes.
According to the family tree presented in
the inscription, Achaemenes founded the dynasty
and was succeeded by his son, Teispes.
There is some corroborating evidence not only
that Teispes existed, but that he captured
the city of Anshan and became king.
Here is where the family tree branches in
two directions as Teispes had two sons: Cyrus
I, grandfather of Cyrus the Great, and Ariaramnes,
great-grandfather of Darius.
When Darius became king, he married two of
Cyrus’s daughters, and later his granddaughter,
thus merging the branches once again.
So it is possible that the lineage is that
straightforward, but here is the problem that
many scholars have with this notion.
Cyrus himself makes almost no mention of Achaemenes.
In the Cyrus Cylinder, which we will talk
about a bit later, Cyrus identifies himself
as a son of Cambyses, a grandson of Cyrus,
and a descendant of Teispes, but no Achaemenes.
The only reference is an inscription on a
column at the ruins of Palace P in Pasargadae
which says “I am Cyrus the king, an Achaemenid.”
This could have easily been added later and
some archaeologists believe that was, indeed,
the case.
They opine it was the work of Darius who wanted
to strengthen his claim to the throne and
establish continuity with the previous kings
who, until him, had always been direct descendants
of the previous rulers.
The War with Lydia
Back to Cyrus, he had conquered the Kingdom
of Media and brought it, as well as its vassals,
under his command.
Unsurprisingly, not everyone was ok with his
conquests.
Specifically, he earned the ire of King Croesus
of Lydia who was the brother-in-law of Astyages.
Croesus was famed for his vast wealth and,
even today, you might hear people described
as being “richer than Croesus”.
You might also know him for his ill-fated
counsel from the Oracle of Delphi.
He sent the priestesses there priceless gifts
such as statues and vessels made out of gold
and asked them if he should send an army against
Cyrus.
The oracle, also known as the Pythia, replied
that “if Croesus goes to war he will destroy
a great empire.”
Never did it occur to him that it might be
his own.
So the Lydians crossed the Halys River into
Cappadocia and captured the city of Pteria,
most likely in 547 BC.
Cyrus mustered his own army and marched to
regain his land.
The two sides met in battle and fought to
a stalemate with both sustaining heavy casualties.
Strategically, it was a victory for the Persians
as Croesus fell back to the Lydian capital
of Sardis.
His plan was to wait out the winter and, in
spring, attack again with a larger army which
included his allies such as the Egyptians,
the Babylonians, and the Spartans.
Foolishly, Croesus disbanded his remaining
soldiers, thinking that Cyrus would never
march on Sardis with winter fast approaching.
But the Persian king did just that.
Cyrus knew that his best shot at victory would
be a quick assault before Croesus gathered
reinforcements.
The two armies fought again in December at
the Battle of Thymbra where Cyrus scored a
decisive victory.
According to Herodotus, the winning strategy
came courtesy of Harpagus.
The Lydians had a large and powerful cavalry.
To counter that, Harpagus advised Cyrus to
put his frontline soldiers on the dromedary
camels they brought along to carry food and
cargo.
His reasoning was that horses were afraid
of camels and even hated their smell and would
turn to flee when they met.
Indeed, this was the case, and many Lydian
soldiers were thrown off their mounts and
quickly dispatched by the Persian infantry
running behind the camels.
Most of the Lydian army surrendered.
What was left of Croesus’s forces retreated
to Sardis but, of course, Cyrus followed closely
and laid siege.
Croesus hoped that his allies might still
come and save the day if he could hold out
long enough.
Alas, the siege lasted only 14 days.
The Persians entered Sardis by scaling a section
of the wall that was completely unguarded.
The grounds outside were so steep that they
were thought to be unclimbable, but a soldier
named Hyroeades proved that it was possible
and the rest of the Persians quickly followed
suit.
And so Sardis fell and, with it, the Kingdom
of Lydia which, after 650 years, became a
province of the Achaemenid Empire.
The fate of Croesus is a question that remains
unanswered today.
According to Herodotus, Cyrus intended to
burn him on a pyre, but the god Apollo sent
a rain to put out the flames.
Seeing that the former Lydian king had divine
protection, Cyrus allowed him to stay on as
one of his courtiers, as he did with Astyages.
Of course, this is a rather fanciful tale
where the once-mighty king gets a happy ending.
The poet Bacchylides said that Croesus wanted
to burn himself alive, but that Apollo took
pity on him and sent him with the Hyperboreans,
a mythological race of giants, in the land
of the north.
Scholars have interpreted this as a poetic
way of saying that the king had a peaceful
death.
The last piece of evidence which suggests
that Croesus, indeed, died during the fall
of Sardis, is the Nabonidus Chronicle, once
again.
It states that, in the year 547/546 BC, during
the month of Ajaru (which corresponds to April/May),
Cyrus marched against a country, killed its
king and took its possessions.
The only problem is that the inscription is
partially damaged and we can’t make out
the name of the country.
It could have been Lydia or it could have
been someplace else.
The Fall of Babylon
Cyrus continued his conquering ways and captured
many cities in Asia Minor and Mesopotamia.
So it happened until there was only one other
power left in all of western Asia - the Neo-Babylonian
Empire, ruled by King Nabonidus whose chronicle
we have used and will continue to use as a
main source.
Unsurprisingly, war erupted between the two
nations.
Unfortunately, while we know the major points,
we have very little detail on the war.
The only large-scale battle that we know of
took place at Opis in 539 BC and it was a
decisive victory for the Persians.
Days later, they took the city of Sippar which
surrendered without any bloodshed.
Interestingly enough, multiple sources indicate
that Cyrus walked into Babylon itself without
battle.
And here we arrive at another contentious
point.
The Cyrus Cylinder, for instance, portrays
the Persian king as a liberator who was welcomed
with open arms by the Babylonians.
This is not completely out of the question,
as Nabonidus might have been an unpopular
king who angered his people by ignoring Marduk,
the patron god of Babylon, and trying to enact
a religious reform based around the worship
of the Moon god Sin.
The Nabonidus Chronicle also says that the
army of Cyrus entered Babylon “without battle”,
but does not provide us with any juicy details.
This could mean that the people were happy
with their new king, but it could also fall
in line with differing ancient accounts which
say that the two armies simply fought outside
the capital.
However it happened, the outcome was the same:
mighty Babylon had fallen and was now part
of the Achaemenid Empire, never to be an independent
power again.
The Satrapies
Now Cyrus was King of the Four Corners of
the World, a title meant to denote a person
who ruled over the whole of Mesopotamia.
However, he was faced with a new problem - how
would he oversee and manage the largest empire
the world had ever known?
Obviously, he couldn’t be everywhere at
once, but his kingdom would be full of issues
which demanded his attention - from serious
problems like riots, uprisings, and food shortages
to mundane affairs like taxes and military
recruitment.
Cyrus employed a primitive version of a federal
government.
He divided his empire into administrative
units known as satrapies which were run by
governors called satraps.
Twenty-six satraps were appointed in Cyrus’s
time and they ruled in his name, dealing with
all the issues that might arise in their regions.
They had a lot of authority, but Cyrus had
the forethought not to give them too much
unchecked power.
There were still officials who were outside
the purview of satraps and reported straight
to the king.
They included army generals, finance officials,
as well as a special courtier who went from
one satrapy to another to conduct inspections,
known as the “eye of the king”.
Truth be told, this was a strategy that Cyrus
borrowed from the Median Empire.
They used client kings who acted as governors
over smaller autonomous areas, but Cyrus was
the first to employ them on a large scale.
This innovative approach to the administration
of a large empire proved successful, even
as Cyrus’s successors continued his expansionist
ways to add new kingdoms to their land.
A testament to this was the fact that the
empire lasted for another 200 years after
Cyrus’s death until it was conquered by
Alexander the Great.
By comparison, Alexander’s empire immediately
collapsed and splintered after he was gone.
The Cyrus Cylinder
Perhaps another factor which helped stabilize
the Achaemenid Empire was Cyrus’s alleged
policy of tolerance.
There are multiple historical and religious
texts which assert that Cyrus allowed the
people he conquered to practice their own
customs and religions.
He endeared himself to the Babylonians by
taking part in their New Year celebrations
and obtaining the blessing of the god Marduk.
In the Bible, it says that he allowed the
exiled Babylonian Jews to return to their
lands.
Consequently, he is referred to as an “anointed”
of God.
One artifact that was greatly responsible
for Cyrus’s reputation as a liberator and
champion of human rights is the Cyrus Cylinder.
Recovered from the ruins of Babylon, it now
sits in the British Museum and is often hailed
as the first charter on human rights in the
world.
This view was chiefly promoted in 1971 by
Mohammad Reza Pahlavi, the last Shah of Iran,
during the 2,500-year celebration of the Persian
Empire.
The idea was continued by the United Nations,
but it is one that historians and scholars
are not very happy with.
They see the cylinder as a priceless artifact,
but one that is filled with standard propaganda.
Basically, it portrays Nabonidus as an unjust
ruler and shows Cyrus as the liberator chosen
by Marduk to come save the Babylonians.
It is in line with Mesopotamian traditions
and should not be regarded as anything more
than a political declaration.
The Demise of Cyrus
The death of Cyrus ends with one big question
mark as there are, at least, five different
outcomes according to ancient sources.
Although some assert that the king died peacefully
at home, most agree that Cyrus met his end
in battle.
Against whom, exactly, is the bone of contention.
Herodotus, again, gives one of the most detailed
accounts, although even he admits that he
heard multiple stories and this is simply
the one he deemed “most worthy of credit.”
In 530 BC, Cyrus fought the Massagetae, a
nomadic Scythian tribe ruled by Queen Tomyris.
Cyrus first extended an offer of marriage
to the queen which she refused, although another
source presented Tomyris as the wife of Cyrus.
Either way, the two armies were supposed to
meet in open battle, but Cyrus set a trap
for the Massagetian troops and killed many
of them, including the general Spargapises
who also happened to be the queen’s son.
Angered by this deception, Tomyris gathered
all her remaining forces and met the Persians
in a fierce battle where she emerged triumphant.
Most of the Persians had been slain, Cyrus
included, ending his reign of 29 years.
Not satisfied, Tomyris tracked down his body,
decapitated him and dipped Cyrus’s head
in a pool of blood so that the king might
fill his bloodlust which cost Tomyris the
death of her son.
The Tomb of Cyrus
The remains of Cyrus were interred in a mausoleum
in the capital of Pasargadae, named after
his tribe.
The ruins of this ancient city still exist
today near the city of Shiraz, in modern day
Iran, and the most treasured landmark is the
tomb of Cyrus.
Oddly enough, the tomb might have not been
around today were it not for the greatest
enemy of the Achaemenid Empire - Alexander
the Great, who was an admirer of Cyrus.
Greek historian Arrian related how the Macedonian
king paid a visit to Cyrus’s tomb after
conquering his empire.
He was deeply angered to discover that thieves
had desecrated it and stolen almost everything
of value.
The golden lid on top of Cyrus’s coffin
was gone; his body had been thrown to the
floor, perhaps in a failed attempt to steal
the entire coffin which proved too heavy.
Alexander ordered the tomb repaired and Cyrus’s
remains restored to their proper place.
He also had the guards of the monument arrested
and tortured so they would give him the names
of the thieves.
Also there was an inscription which does not
exist anymore so the exact wording is iffy.
It said: “O man, I am Cyrus, son of Cambyses,
who founded the empire of Persia
and ruled over Asia.
Do not grudge me my monument.”